That was an example of one type of memory, but there are three types of memory.
The first type of memory is called Sensory memory, do you remember back in
lesson three the brain lesson? And also our sensation and perception lesson,
how we talked about our different sensory systems? And how they're stimulated
by the things that we smell, taste, touch, feel, hear and experience. Sensory
memory is made of the brief traces of the sensation left by the firing neurons
in the brain. These traces don't last very long sometimes a half a second or up
to two to three seconds. Nos, sensation is the first step in our ability to
create long term memories, now there's two types of sensory memories let's talk
about those next.